aaron rodgers
won super bowl appearance won super bowl
victory in his tenure that came way back
in 2010
the questions still linger about what
he's going to do now
here is a story that isn't about rogers
as much as it's about maybe some of the
behind the scenes maneuvering from a pr
standpoint
the story from tuesday morning from adam
schefter that rogers turned down during
the off-season a contract offer that
would have made him the highest paid
player in the nfl
first of all
that's not new
and it's not uncommon
for reporters to dust off old news and
maybe add some little twist to it to to
justify making it a headline but
if adam schafter's being honest with
himself and with the audience he would
admit that this is months old this has
been out there that during the
conversations that occurred during the
quiet time in the off-season before
rogers made it known that he wanted out
the packers had indeed offered him a
contract that would have made him the
highest paid player in football but
there continues to be a major gap when
it comes to the information that's been
reported
when you don't know the structure of the
deal it doesn't matter what the deal is
worth you put a couple of non-guaranteed
years on the back end that bump the
average salary up over 45 million per
year hey he's the highest paid player in
football well yeah but
does it affect the fundamental problem
that motivated all of this effort by
rogers and this goes back to january and
this is what we've said consistently
rogers no longer wants to be
one year at a time employed by the
packers he wants security he wants to
know he'll be there two or three years
so he doesn't have to worry about being
supplanted by jordan love
if you give him a contract that has a
bunch of non-guaranteed money that makes
him
more highly paid than patrick holmes but
there's no guarantee he's going to be
there to make that money who cares
so the structure is the key a contract
that forces the packers to keep aaron
rodgers for 2020 1 2022 and maybe 2023
that's what he wants that's what let me
be more accurate
that's what he wanted
it may be that the ship has sailed and
if they would show up now and say
okay aaron we'll give you what you
wanted back in january or february it
could be an errand where rogers will say
hey look you had your chance
to do what you needed to do then you
jerked me around you forced me to play
this game i didn't want to play this
game i just wanted to have a deal that
made me know i was going to be here that
i was the guy that you're as committed
to me as i am to you you didn't do it
you decided to go the hard way and now
i'm i'm going the even harder way and
i'm going to continue to persist in my
desire to be traded and i still think
and i i said this yesterday where did i
say it i think i said it on dan
patrick's show and some people have
misinterpreted what i said i'm not
reporting that rogers is going to show
up and that he's going to get traded
before week one i just could envision
roger's showing up
the packers specifically ceo mark murphy
not being happy with that outcome i
think murphy would prefer that roger's
not show then rogers becomes the villain
in all of this and the packers if roger
sits out the whole year they they can
make more than 30 million dollars back
from rogers between salary that won't be
paid signing bonus that can be recovered
roster bonus that won't be paid fines if
they collect them they're looking at
more than 30 million if he chooses to
boycott the whole year if he shows up it
could be that the packers finally soften
in their stance that they're not going
to trade him this whole we're not going
to trade you may be aimed at goading him
into not showing up if he shows up they
may say you know we're better off moving
on do we really want this awkward final
season with aaron rodgers where we
constantly have to worry about what kind
of verbal shots he's going to take while
standing in front of his locker i don't
know that the packers are going to want
that if it comes to it and that's why i
think showing up could be the key to
rogers ending up in what most likely at
this point would be denver for the 2021
season i can't rule out anything we've
seen so many crazy things happen in the
nfl over the years how can you rule out
any possible permutation or outcome of
this rogers drama but the bottom line is
this today's report from schefter is not
new and that news continues to be
incomplete because we don't know the
structure and finally this gets back to
my original point i think schefter's
doing somebody from the packers a favor
here because here we are six days away
from the shareholder meeting and i've
pointed out mark murphy is going to face
a hostile crowd the packers want it to
be known that they've done everything in
their power to get rogers to stay and
the fact that rogers is still upset
doesn't reflect unreasonableness on
their part it reflects unreasonableness
on his part
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports